downtown Frankfort is home to a number
of the tallest skyscrapers in Europe
Reinhart Klein Ville is here to set a
new record by slacklining some 185
meters above the ground as the name
suggests slacklines are not as taut as
tight ropes making it harder to balance
the vicinity honor the decease itself
the fascinating part is challenging
yourself doing something that feels
dangerous and that you can do safely
it's that discrepancy that I find so
interesting I see cubed I'm come and
visit disco pants Vinnie sent us on a
fall from up here without a safety line
would obviously be fatal so just in case
he has a harness attached to the rope
but he still has to stay fully focused
World Records like this don't come
easily his audience of course are some
distance away on the ground climb dolls
daredevil walk is one of the highlights
of a two-day skyscraper themed festival
that was held this weekend in Frankfurt
lastly not doing this one day heard it's
the height that makes it so special and
the fact that anyone could summon up so
much courage absurd nordhoff bling this
isn't it's a risk despite the safety
line imagine the incredible
concentration and imagine losing your
coordination I certainly wouldn't do it
shuts wish Mambo assets initially does
have a backup but even then there's no
one hundred percent guarantee so I say
respect for Bayern respect a few days
previously in Austria Reinhardt Klein
drew is gearing up for his world-record
attempt he practices on a 30 meter long
line tensioned between two trees he uses
a winch to give the slackline the right
amount of tension but these conditions
are a world away from the dizzy heights
he'll be facing in Frankfurt oh it's
fila for our own thoughts Tamim aveda
for all the experience you might have
you always encounter problems once
you're up there from hesitation to panic
as a phone via villip and you wonder why
am i doing this thing forgiving good
your knees go wobbly and you start
seeing double okay everything really see
toy stop food as a fully spoke on wobbly
knees have never been an obstacle to
Reinhardt climbed up whether scaling
church towers in Austria or where he's
really in his element in the mountains
this video shows the extreme sports
enthusiasts braving a 31 metre long high
line across the famous three peaks in
the Italian Dolomites
reinhart klein bill got into slacklining
almost by accident 6 years ago when some
friends took him along to a park for
some practice he just graduated from
college and was looking for a new
pursuit he took two slacklining like
most people do to bicycle riding it was
second nature you simply mapa bible
study most certain movements are
conscious but most are from intuition
because things happen so suddenly what I
find fascinating is having to trust your
own body and your own abilities
especially on the high line where you
have nothing to hold on to your only
source of stability moves and shakes
exeunt ship it's a strip down and we're
back to the big day in Frankfurt where
Reinhardt climbed Elizabeth line between
the two wings of the fourth highest
building in Germany keep breathing and
just don't look down it would be the
first time anyone has traversed a
slackline at this kind of height and he
makes it
leriq what is didn't eat us wetly the
record is not about the sporting
performance the record is about doing
something special the height let's keep
a bar there are far higher skyscrapers
out there so I'm wondering who's going
to do them it had been nice to break his
own new record of course what for others
is death-defying recklessness is a labor
of love for Reinhart client
you